il y a plusieurs facteurs c'est sûr que
pour comme on voit que tous les oiseaux
qui qui s'alimentent d'insectes au vol
et diminuent il y a certainement un
problème au niveau des des insectes
peut-être pas l'abondance des insectes
mais peut-être que les les les espèces
d'insectes ont changé dans le temps et
puis bon peut-être la valeur nutritive
de certains insectes qui sont
maintenant plus présents qu'avant et
peut-être pas la même donc l'utilisation
des insecticides est probablement en
cause tout ça pu c'est bon ça peut se
produire ici sur les aires d'ification
mais aussi sur les aires d'hvernage
l'oiseau passe plusieurs mois par année
en Amérique du Sud et en migration entre
les ici et l'Amérique du Sud donc il
peut avoir aussi des problèmes ailleurs
que seulement seement ici et est-ce
qu'il des études qui se font pour
préciser quelle est le coupable il y a
certaines études qui ont été faites
récemment entre autres en Ontario il y a
une étude qui a été publiée où justement
c'est une étude assez euh
particulière c'est un chercheur qui a
été dans une cheminée qui est utilisé
par le martinet depuis 60 ans et puis
dans le fond de la cheminée évidemment
il y a une accumulation de fiant
d'oiseau depuis depuis 60 ans donc il y
a étudié les fiantes au niveau des
insecticides présentes puis des types
d'insectes qui étaient présents dans
dans cette colonne de de fiantes et puis
s'est aperçu que avec l'arrivée du DDT
dans ça l' changé beaucoup les
communautés d'insectes présents donc pas
que la l'utilisation du DDT à l'époque a
causé une baisse de population assez
importante mais ça si ça s'avère vrai si
ça si on c'est confirmé avec le temps ça
veut dire que on va vers quelque chose
de mieux maintenant le DDT étant mis de
côté le DDT a été mis de côté mais pas
nécessairement partout non plus sur les
heures de répartition de l'espèce en
Amérique du Sud l'utilisation du DDT
peut être encore encore là mais aussi
sans doute d'autres facteurs qui
rentrent en ligne de compte le finess
des espèces d'oiseaux qui s'alimentent
d'insect au vol c'est celui qui a baissé
le plus donc on sait qu'il niche dans
des cheminées de des vieilles cheminées
de pierre ou de BRI et puis mais ce type
de vit là va aussi en en diminuant parce
que bon les gens rénovent leur maison
rén leur bâtiments donc le nombre de
cheminées peut-être disponible et de de
qualité suffisante pour le Martinet est
peut-être aussi en déclin donc en plus
de perdre ou d'avoir de la difficulté
peut-être avoir une alimentation
convenable il a aussi c'est une perte
d'habitate ntifation